So please welcome to Google Detroit.
Mrs Kristi hedges.
Well, thank you again for
joining us. We appreciate it. Um,
I mentioned in the Bio Intro, um, so
you wrote a book previously called, um,
the power of presence, right? And this
book is called the inspiration code. Um,
are you able to kind of kick things off
by just telling us a little bit about
how those two things are?
Those two books are similar and
perhaps how they're different, right.
Presence versus inspiration,
they tied together,
but there's obviously
differences between them.
Maybe kick things off with
that and we'll go from there.
Yeah, sure. So what, well, let me start by
saying how I ended up writing this book.
That's a little bit, that's how they're,
they're kind of tied together. Sure. Uh,
so I wrote the power of presence
and came out in 2011. Uh,
and that's really a book about influence.
How do we use our presence to
influence situations around us? Uh,
and as I was out talking
to groups about that,
I would start by asking them the simple
question to come warm up the audience a
little bit. It get people
talking. Uh, and that was, uh,
who inspires you and what did they do?
And I was trying to map those answers
and those characteristics back to people
who had presence and make this
real life connection for people.
What would I notice when
I asked that question?
A pretty immediately was no
matter how tired people were,
maybe it's the day after a holiday
weekend or something like that. Uh,
when they would start talking about
these people who inspired them,
their faces would light up and there
be all this animation and energy in the
room and people would be literally
transformed energetically in front of me.
Uh, and that happened again
and again and again and again.
And people would talk as part of the
exercise about what these people did. Uh,
and I noticed that they communicated in
certain ways, uh, that inspired people.
I mean, to even remember things
and you guys have them now.
Somebody said something to you that just
hits you, just write and those words,
you carry them around and you,
you use them when you need them
and they and fortify you when you,
you sort of need guidance and all
those kinds of good things. Uh,
and I just started writing
down what did these people do?
And I found that these patterns
just emerged again and again. Uh,
and that led me to put them together in a,
in the inspiration code.
Uh,
but as I looked at those,
because I was usually there speaking
to groups to talk about presence.
So talk about influence, which is
really important. Uh, but what we, um,
in leadership development programs,
we often rely so much on influence that
we leave out this other piece about
engagement, which is inspiration.
Uh, and if you think about that,
we need both of them as leaders,
but they go hand in hand. I mean,
none of us go home after a day of work
and say, I still did a great day to day.
I was influenced all day long. Right?
I mean, that, it feels different.
Influence has done to us, but we would
go home and say, I was so inspired today.
I had a great day. Uh,
inspiration comes from within.
So I really wanted to figure out how to
create those feelings in people in the
workplace because we need more of it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You so one of the really interesting
things that I read about in the book is
this kind of the influence of listening,
right?
So we talk about inspiration and when
you think about an inspirational person
person, you think of a great speaker
or somebody with presence, right?
Uh,
one of the things that you mentioned that
was one of the most cited behaviors of
somebody who is inspiring
is the ability to listen.
Can you talk a little bit more about
that? It seems like a simple thing, right?
And listening,
everyone should be able to do it,
but it's not really that
easy of a concept to handle.
A lot of people aren't good at listening.
And you talk about how listening kind of
plays into inspiration and also how we
can work on becoming better listeners in
order to be more aspirational with the
folks that we lead.
Yeah, that was a surprise to me. So
as part of the research that I did,
I also did a quantitative research that
I commissioned on my own and I looked at
what are the behaviors that were
most impactful to people in terms of
inspiration. And the number
one behavior was listening. Uh,
and I also heard in these discussions,
people would say that person was there
for me. Uh, they made time for me.
They were focused on me. Uh, that
came up again and again and again.
So it was clear that there was just
something magical about when somebody
creates a space for us, uh,
through strong listening skills.
So whether you're in sales or
whether you're leading teams, uh,
when we listen to people,
it's a sign of respect for their opinion.
It's a sign that we care. Uh,
there is a, a great quote that, uh,
the currency of love is time and I
would say the currency of respect his
attention. Uh, so when we give people
our attention, it feels different,
but we're not very good
listeners as a group, right?
We learned to listen quick and listen
halfway so we can get done what we need to
get done. And that's why would
somebody really listens to us.
It's sort of like the record skips
and it just feels quite different.
Yeah. And I think another concept you
talked about too is authenticity, right?
We've all encountered leaders who
most likely read a leadership book,
uh, and that's pretty much it, but
there's no authenticity to it, right?
Because they're just kind of spitting
back something that they read about, uh,
you know, being a powerful speaker or
giving someone a strong handshake, right?
That doesn't necessarily
equate to authentic leadership.
It's just something they read
about and look at in a book.
And I think listening is
one of those aspects, uh,
that actually conveys
authenticity. Right. Um,
can you talk about this kind of
concept of authenticity as well?
Not just reading a book about leadership
and kind of spitting it back to your
employees, but how you actually
could become an authentic leader.
In addition to kind of the,
the listening that we talked about,
some other concepts around that.
Yeah, well me listening, I
mean authenticity really is a,
it's about trust when it comes down to us,
you know, we trust people who are real.
So if we don't feel like we
actually know someone, then it's,
it's very difficult for us
to really invest in them. Um,
but authenticity is tricky at work, right?
People can be too authentic as well.
So just trying to figure out
what that fine line is of uh,
your authentic enough so that we know
you. Uh, and yet you're also, you know,
aware of your surroundings and what,
and what the situation will support. Uh,
and so, uh, with authenticity, what I will
often will tell people is that, you know,
we have to,
it really has to start within you.
Like what is your intention for
what you want to get across?
And I'm being very clear about what
I call your personal presence brand,
which is really your values were on
the outside. How do I want to show up?
How do I want people to perceive me?
How do I want to show
what's most important to me?
If you're very clear about that going in,
then you're much more likely for that to
come out in an authentic way because it,
it really is about the core of who
you want to be in that situation. Uh,
but situational awareness matters too.
So also knowing what those,
the room will support because sometimes
we get into to ed needed too much
information. The TMI situation where, wow,
your authenticity is screaming at me
and everyone kind of back it back up.
When we talk about, um, TMI, uh,
sometimes emotion comes
into the discussion as well.
And in terms of leadership and
authenticity, um, Google is,
is known for kind of coming up with
this concept of search inside yourself,
which is this concept based
on of mindfulness and emotion,
uh, within the workplace. And, um,
not a lot of companies were
really thinking about this. Like,
how does this play into kind of
the ecosystem of the workplace?
But I think it's kind of a core emotion
as it is a core aspect of leadership
that a lot of folks don't
necessarily grasp. How do you,
how do you tie emotion into
leadership without being unauthentic?
How do you do it in a way that,
um,
kind of displays a sincerity?
Like you talk a little bit about kind
of the importance of mindfulness or
emotion within kind of the,
the aspects of leadership.
Yeah. Well, the, uh, you know, I just
wrote a piece for Harvard Business Review,
which is a believable, I online this week
hard, go ahead, get emotional at work. Uh,
and,
uh,
and the idea was the fact
that in my world with,
with coaching and leaders that I coach,
it's not the people who bring it too
much emotion and they're not bringing
enough emotion. And, uh, and you know,
emotion is really a signal for us as a
trigger to understand really what you
care about. So if a leader comes in and
they're overly stoic, you know, it's,
it was like a, what's there,
knock, knock, knock, you know,
you're looking for what the,
what the real story is. Uh,
and so emotion is actually something
we want to be very strategic about as
leaders because if we want people to
feel something, we have to bring in.
So if I want people to get excited,
I have to bring excitement into a room.
If I want people to feel serious,
I have to bring series as into a room.
So knowing what emotion you're trying to
impart and instead of trying to either
have it be an afterthought to make
it really important part of your
communication is really what that's about.
So it's a knowing what that emotion is
and then being willing to put it out
there. And, uh, instead of,
you know, a lot of us can have
come up through the ranks,
uh, learning that we want
to be unemotional at work.
We don't want to show,
we want to be always stoic,
you know,
have the same demeanor no
matter what people throw at us.
And as an individual contributor, we get
rewarded for that. Uh, and we're told,
oh gosh, you can give Jason
anything. He's going to, you know,
he's always has a smile on
his face no matter what you
dump on his lap. Right? Uh,
and then you get to be a leader and that
doesn't work so well anymore because
you have to use emotion to get people
excited to make them feel something. And,
and being able to actually think about,
oh gosh,
how should I be emotional at work versus
not having emotion to be something that
we really think about.
Yeah. I feel like we sometimes it Google
and counter the opposite of that as well
though, where when you're
an individual contributor,
then individual contributor or
you're newer to the company company,
you bring more emotion,
right? You're like, okay,
I'm me Google.
This is exciting.
People are more emotional.
They're more emotional in their
interactions with their managers.
But then as you progress and you
become part of the leadership team,
maybe you're a manager or you
manage a team or you're a director,
you feel like you have to be more serious
and more stoic and you actually remove
the emotion because you want to be
respected and authoritative versus,
you know, an individual contributor
that's a little bit more free and open.
You see that as well as being kind
of a concept that comes up across in
inspiration where when folks get
into a position of leadership,
they actually lose some of those traits
of a good leader because they feel they
have to based on maybe an antiquated
vision of what a leader is.
Yeah. Well exactly right. And that's what,
I love that example where people come
in and they're like all gung Ho. Sure.
As a leader like that. Exactly. Yeah.
I guess we don't want our leaders have
excited. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Uh, and,
and you know, it's kind of funny
as we talk about it, but you,
you see that play out. There's,
you know, as you say that it just,
it makes me think about how
we think about, we quit joy,
a joyfulness at work with
naivete. Sure. Uh, and,
and that doesn't serve us
very well because wouldn't
it be great to have leaders
who were actually joyful about the
work that they did versus coming in and
feeling like it's a grind every day,
uh, that, that doesn't inspire anybody.
So, uh, it's, it's really thinking, again,
we don't think about things on
an emotional plane very much,
but if you just think about
it as a leader, you know,
and play around with the idea of motion
as being a critical part of how you
communicate. That opens up a lot that
maybe we don't even think we have.
Sure. Can you talk kind of
tying that topic together too?
So your book talks a lot
about inspiring others. Um,
can you maybe kind of turn that inward
a bit and talk about how leaders,
so folks here in the room,
folks that are watching,
who are in positions of
influence or leadership,
how they can inspire themselves
from a leadership perspective,
how can they,
if maybe they're one of these more
stoic leaders and then something just,
you know, the, the last comment you made
something snapped in the, is it they wait,
I'm one of these stoic leaders,
how can I inspire myself to be a
little bit more joyful, more mindful,
more emotional work?
What are some practices or ways that
folks who are in a position of leadership
can,
can inspire themselves?
Well, everything that a
I wrote in the book, uh,
that as far as other people also
inspires you. And I'll be honest,
that didn't even hit me
until the end of the book.
So I was writing it
and then wait a minute.
But we could use these
things on ourselves. Uh, and,
and that's great because that's the idea.
It's a virtuous cycle.
So when we inspire other people,
we also get inspired and it,
and it all plays into the same
thing. Uh, but for example,
one of the top ways that what we were
saying that earlier that people get
inspired is through conversation, through
communication with other people. Uh,
you can get inspired reading your email,
but you probably won't. Uh, it's probably,
you know, it's sitting like this
listening to other people talk.
I'm thinking about things.
I know you guys do a lot of that.
A Google bringing ideas in from the
outside just to expand your mind a little
bit and get you to think differently.
Uh, and, and so, you know,
with leaders that I've worked with, often
they'll get to a place where, you know,
they've achieved a great level of success,
but they just don't feel all that
inspired anymore about it. Uh,
and then I'll ask, well, who
do you talk to during the day?
And they talked to the same people.
They talked to their management team.
They might go out and talk to
some customers occasionally. Uh,
they talked to the board.
Um, whatever the case is,
but they don't actually have
any new inputs coming in. And,
and so to really go out and seek
inspiration to find people to have
conversations with two, if you don't
have any role models to find some,
cause they might not be
sitting around the office, uh,
you might have to look outward for that.
And to put yourself in places that just
really help you open your mind can be a
great pathway to inspiration.
Sure.
You speak,
obviously you're here at Google today,
you speak to a lot of other companies,
you speak at schools,
you speak at businesses.
Are there any kind of really interesting
techniques that you've absorbed from
speaking at these different places? Uh,
folks that are doing, I guess either a,
a really great job of inspiring
their employees or their students or,
or whatever it may be,
or on the flip side,
be doing a really poor job at doing it,
but maybe in a forceful way or an
inauthentic way as we discussed earlier?
Well, I'll tell you something
that, uh, that I see a lot,
so I don't want, you know,
and I'm not calling out anybody.
Yeah. Then then there you go.
Is that company spent a lot of money
and time on corporate mission statements
and corporate visions.
Uh,
and it's not that they don't
matter because they do matter.
They just don't matter enough.
Uh,
and they don't look at what are the
conversations that are happening every day
and organizations between managers and
their people and teams and you know,
what is the,
you know,
I always say like cultures are really
just stories built upon stories in the
organization.
There,
there aren't enough sort of fresh stories
getting into the mix about things that
are working and things that,
um,
solutions that are being overcome and
until they're really hanging their hat on
this beautiful mission statement,
uh,
and yet everybody in the organization
doesn't buy it because the culture doesn't
support it.
So I see a lot of that where we,
we look at the very high level though.
So the grand ideas of inspiration and
we've heard that you have to have a great
vision.
So we checked that box and we spent a lot
of money checking that box and then we
just wait for everybody's
behavior to change. Uh,
and it doesn't really get embedded
down to the individual level. I mean,
what inspires us as our day to day
interactions with people around us. Sure.
Uh, what are some common
mistakes people make? Uh,
we've talked a lot about the
positive things that people can do.
We talked about in that authenticity
is maybe I guess a mistake,
but are there other things that you
see people making on a daily, monthly,
weekly basis? Uh, mistakes
that the good leadership, uh,
folks that should know better or actually
making a mistake so we can kind of
understand and avoid learning
from past mistakes, I suppose.
Yeah. Yeah, sure. Well, you know,
it's one we just talked about at lunch
and I'll just bring it up because it's
very current. Uh, is that, uh,
one of the most inspiring conversations
a leader can have is to be in talks with
their people about their teams,
about their purpose.
So helping them really identify
how is your purpose for yourself.
I'm being played out and being supported
in the, in the position that you're in.
But that seems like a really great
conversation, but it doesn't have to be.
So just talking about
contextualized purpose,
so how does what you're doing today,
but just help you take a couple steps
further along in your development.
It can be that simple,
but often managers don't want to be in
that conversation because they'll worry.
That's gonna it has some, they're,
they're, they're, uh, you know,
team members going to have an epiphany
and then go out the door, uh, with that.
And so they don't want that
to happen. So like, well,
I'm not going to have the
purpose conversation cause
I might lose them. Uh, and,
and that's a real missed opportunity,
uh, because first of all,
we love when people engage us
in that larger question, um,
because we're thinking about it or we
want to be thinking about it. Sure. Uh,
and somebody creates a space for
us. It's very meaningful. Uh,
and then also often there are
things that you don't see that,
uh, that somebody around you might see
the can pull some threads together.
And help you understand that.
Let's say you're working in a,
in a company that's very chaotic,
um,
well that chaos might be really teaching
you how to manage a lot of complexity,
what you're going to need for
the next level of your career.
So somebody can help you see that all of
a sudden that chaotic environment isn't
a grind just to manage through every day.
It's a,
it's a huge learning opportunity and
you may not see that yourself. So being,
be willing to be in those conversations
is quite powerful and we don't have them
enough.
Yeah.
Oftentimes people want to build on the
base of what they have without analyzing
that base, right? So there's, how
can I be more inspiring? I'll do a,
B and c without fixing what
was wrong in the first place.
So we often look at how you can improve
upon what you're currently doing.
And then once you feel like
you've kind of fixed that base,
then you proceed with
some of the tips from,
from the book in terms of how you can
inspire the competitor yourself. Um,
a lot of the book talks, yeah. It
kind of in context of, uh, you know,
inspiring in a, in a
corporate setting. Um,
are there ways that you can
take a lot of these kind of, um,
topics and themes that apply to them
outside of the corporate world as well?
Yes. I mean, everything in the book, uh,
works in any environment you're in. So,
uh, I have found myself starting to use
these at home with my kids a lot more.
That's what I'm asking. Yeah. I'm
sorry. Uh, let me think about that.
Uh, and it's great. They do a,
and so it doesn't matter if
you're, you're trying to, I mean,
there's a lot of inspiration
going on in communities, right.
And I was on inspiration
going on in Detroit right now.
Uh, and, and so, you know,
using these kinds of ideas about
what really gets people inspired,
what lights up, lights people up. Uh, it's
any group you're, you can imagine it's,
it's your teams at work.
It's your communities at home.
It's the schools that you're working
in a, it doesn't matter. It's,
it's the same stuff, which
is the beauty of it. Right?
I love when things will apply
at work and apply at home. Uh,
and that's really what I, I
tried to do last time. Um,
with the power of presence to, it doesn't
really matter where you have presence,
it's all the same result.
We talked a little bit right before
we hopped on stage here about, uh,
how inspiration can be contagious.
And we talked about the city of Detroit,
which were all located in right now,
uh,
and how Detroit has seen better days.
But what happened was there was a few
inspired individuals who started to live,
apply inspiration to certain their house,
to a neighborhood,
a street, uh, whatever it may be.
And it spread very quickly, right?
We saw this inspiration
spread very quickly. Um,
but I feel like that same concept, uh,
this, this took place in a major us city,
that same concept can also be
applied to the workplace, right?
So if you're in an uninspired workplace,
having a few individuals
that bring inspiration, that,
that learn how to be inspiring
individuals, it can catch on it.
It could be contagious as well.
Right?
Absolutely. And I sit here with my
Shinola watch on, right. So supporting.
Beautiful. Yeah. We were saying,
I've been lurking watching Detroit for
years and just rooting for Detroit and
just so inspired by what's
happening here. Uh, so,
so there is actually a, um,
a scientifically researched,
well researched,
a theory called emotional contagion.
And so we always sort of think about
it just in layman's terms as you know,
Kinda you catch somebody bad who don't
bring people down, right? Debbie Downer.
We catch people's bad moods or,
or whatever the case is,
but it's actually verifiable as humans,
we do pick up the moods of other people.
Uh, and we develop as groups what,
what sociologists call group aspect,
which is we kind of,
we kind of go towards the center of
whatever the mood is in a particular
organization.
Now,
leaders actually have more power to
shift that mood than anybody else because
people may pay more attention to leaders.
We pay attention up the hierarchy.
So if the leader is cynical,
the group's gonna feel cynical.
If the leader's optimistic, we're
going to feel optimistic. Uh,
and so absolutely it is contagious.
So,
but you need those people to come in and
be the brave ones to be the beach head
for whatever emotion is that you're
trying to, to get people to impart a,
and of course there's safety in numbers,
so if you get a few people really
excited than that, that tends to,
to change the dynamic of a
much larger organization.
But it has to start with somebody.
Sure. And we talked about in the
city of Detroit, Dan Gilbert, not by,
by Fart, excuse me, not the only person,
but obviously one of the figureheads of,
of some positivity around Detroit.
And he instilled a lot of inspiration to
people by investing a lot of his money
into the city. And again, a lot of
people, when they saw that happen,
a lot of folks who were outside the city,
we're in the city who hadn't necessarily
invested now or investing time and
money to help kind of
inspire the city as well.
So Dan Gilbert's one that
comes to mind in Detroit.
Did you have any other leaders that,
that kind of are inspiring
to you folks that, uh,
it either in your hometown or
folks in your industry, uh,
authors that have kind of really embraced
this idea of inspiration and presence
and authenticity,
folks that have really inspired you?
Well, I'm in Washington DC, so lots
of inspiration there. Yeah, of course.
It's a lot inspiration. All guys of
the boys. Uh, it's, yeah. So, yes,
I mean I get inspired by
people all the time and a,
and I'll just tell you personally
from me right now, I'm,
I'm quite inspired by people who are
maybe 20 years further along in their
career than I am because I'm
starting to look and think, okay,
this next phase of my life.
Like how can I be most inspiring in that
and using my talents and do the things
that, um, that I think are going
to be important beyond myself. Uh,
and I'm very inspired by people
who've been there before. And,
and role modeling is just, it's such a
huge, we talked about earlier too, it,
it role models are inspiring to us
because they create a vicarious experience
for when we see somebody like Dan
Gilbert come in and do that, um,
were inspired because we see him
do something and we think, well,
I could maybe do that too. So I maybe I
can, you know, buy a whole building. Um,
but maybe I can put a couple of my people
in that building. Yup. Right. So we,
we make another step and then
that's what role models do for us.
So I'm really looking at, uh,
uh, people who are, you know,
have a real need and energy around being
in service and then how they're doing
that in their lives.
And so I have,
I'm lucky enough to have a couple of
people that I've sought out because they
didn't land in my lap and I,
and I tried to spend time with
them and I see what they do. Uh,
and I always leave those conversations
just no, 10 feet tall and, and,
and we need that.
We need those people.
Absolutely. Um, we got
shifting topics a little bit,
but still kind of tying into what we were
just talking about is kind of the idea
of diversity,
right?
So diversity not in the sense of what
people look like or where they're from,
but the diversity of cultures,
diversity of backgrounds,
diversity of professional experiences,
uh,
incredibly important and a huge topic
and incredibly important for Google,
a huge topic in the media these days.
How do you kind of tie this idea of
diversity into authentic leadership and
inspiration and presence is,
is there a way to kind of tie in what
you were just mentioning bringing in
diversity from other folks and really
kind of bringing that altogether and in a
way that makes sense for a company
or a family or whatever it may be.
I don't know, but I'll, I'll try.
Yeah. Like we're all trying of course.
Uh, as well. Uh, the research
supports that, you know,
diverse organizations perform
better. Sure. Right. We know
that at the board level,
you know, throughout organizations. Uh,
I believe that the reason that that's the
case is because of the input idea that
I just talked about with the inspiration.
When we see things from
people's experience, it just
expands our own perspective.
It's so Weber cultural blinders we have
and you can define cultural however you
want.
Um,
they get widened when we see things
that we previously didn't see because
somebody else's helped us see that.
Like we've weathered through role modeling
or being with them or discussion or
whatever the case is. Uh, so,
so we learn a lot more people become
three when they're in front of us and,
and you know, we know them and we can,
we can understand that more. Um, we're a,
you know, a global world, you
know, it's, you know, and a
trite phrase, but it's true.
Like we work with people.
I work with people all over the world.
You guys probably do the same.
Uh,
and so diversity of everything
is important because it
just allows us to be in
the world and, and, uh, with
a, a broader perspective,
the two perspectives are huge.
Getting perspectives from different
people and countries and everything.
Culture is a huge,
huge difference maker.
What's one piece of advice you would give
us as Google speaking to us as Google
today in terms of inspiration?
Is there,
is there anything you've heard or
read that we do good or bad that could
potentially be turned into
advice that we can walk away,
walk away with today?
Well, I mean Google is known for a lot
of the things that we just talked about.
So,
uh,
you guys are lucky cause you're sitting
in organizations like that and not all
of the organizations I work
with, I can say the same, uh,
what I admire from Google from afar. So
I don't work in the company. But what I,
what I see is, is just the, uh, you,
you mentioned the word curiosity before,
but that's what I see.
I see just a hunger and a curiosity to
learn and expand and try new things.
Uh,
and you know,
when you have that sort of permeating
the culture, even, even today,
so we're having a Google talk
we talked about earlier of,
I said your diploma seat, right?
Because you helped put these together,
that means that you get to
learn, you know, a lot about
things that you might be,
you care about. Uh, but all Google
has that opportunity. So I think, uh,
having that kind of
mindset, uh, and to be, uh,
to be an outspoken leader and things that,
uh,
from a business standpoint and
the corporate community, uh,
which Google does a frequently, uh, is
inspiring to a lot of other organizations.
And you, and you see that, you see, um,
there are a select number of companies
and Google's one of them can,
that can put out a pretty bold statement
and you see other companies lining up
behind them and there's a
responsibility with that. Uh,
the Google seems to take it pretty well.
Yeah,
well,
we do our best.
We do our best to be inspirational
is as a company and as individual
contributors here and the city of Detroit.
But it's hard, right? It's, it's a,
it's a simple concept, but putting it
into practice, uh, is, is it takes,
it does take practice itself.
It takes practice and understanding
and cognizance more than anything. Um,
I wanted to open up now I'm sure we've
got some questions from the audience.
We have a lot of leadership
here in the room. Um,
wanting to open up for questions.
If anyone has any questions,
if that we can ask Christy. Um, I do
have Mike's here if you want to court,
if you don't mind running those for us.
Thank you.
Nice for you, Jason. Hi, Dave Hoffman. Um,
and this is one of my main types this
close to my heart and went back to get my
MBA space specifically based on
corporate cultures, things like that. Um,
I, I'm an ex athlete and it's always funny
how the best team doesn't always win,
stolen the team that has the most hard,
most best leadership and inspiration,
all those kinds of things.
Um,
one of the things that I found kind of
time and time again is that natural light
that God given brilliant seems to
really hinder your ability to be an
inspirational leader. You
know, you get so caught up in,
in how things work or he or your mind
and whatever that you tend to not be as
personable, as outgoing. Um,
and that seems to be the case
sometimes here at Google where we,
we lack a little bit of inspirational
leadership because they just,
that Eeq kind of isn't there.
So first,
like what are some of the traits where
you can actually help coach someone up
into that from a leadership perspective
or the other end of the spectrum where
somebody might be a little bit more
fast and loose. So a lot of energy,
but at the same time needs to find a way
to authentically dial it back down so
that they can kind of fit into that
mold of a leader without losing their,
their uniqueness or their genuineness.
Sure. There's a couple
of questions. Yeah. Uh,
but I like where you're going and
let me just say that, uh, athletes,
often people who were former athletes,
our athletes are often really get
this because a lot of it is a,
starts in the inside that mental game.
So really being clear about that. And,
and if you have been an athlete,
a lot of times I wasn't an athlete,
I've heard this,
um,
that that's been part of the training
and it's a positive visualization, um,
plays a big role in it.
So I'm not surprised to hear the
connection that you just made between
athleticism and then, and culture. Uh,
so the being in your head problems
and interesting one a time,
a blessing and a curse because often if
we're someone who spends a lot of time
conceptualizing,
and maybe that's our personality or maybe
we're an introvert and that's how we
process or, or whatever the case, um,
it means that our first instinct might
not be to communicate right at first
instinct is to cut this a step
back and think about it. Uh,
and when I work with leaders like that,
which I do all the time because a lot of
people are introverts and, and that's,
that's where they naturally go.
Uh,
it's to get them out of
that predisposition that
things have to be perfect
before I communicate
it. Right. And so, yeah,
I'm thinking of someone that I worked
with several years ago. And so my,
one of my pieces of advice to him
was, uh, you know, you need to,
you need to go for, um, intentional
transparency is what I called it a,
because you think that people are
reading your mind but no one knows what's
going on up in here. Uh, and so you
need to be very intentional about it.
So your first instinct when you get new
piece of information or when you have a
plan that's maybe 50% bacon on 100% big
is to tell people like you need to get
that knee jerk reaction. Because
if it's just you thinking about it,
then it doesn't really shape anything.
So,
so that's one thing that comes up quite a
bit, if that, if that makes sense. Sure.
Thanks. Cool. Questions, Ashley?
Um, hotline. Here we
go. How's this? Better?
Okay, great. Um, so in
addition to, to be an author,
you consult and work with large
companies. And so I'm, you
know, I'm considering here
kind of thinking about all
these principles and how we
might push them down through a company
like Google or through one of the
companies that we support in this room,
which are large automakers,
the GM or Ford or Chrysler.
Um,
so when you think about tackling
a huge corporate client like that,
let's say budget was no option,
no issue in the CEO said,
I need your help transforming my
leadership. What are, you know,
what are some of the levers or the tools
that you would use with the company and
what do you think would be required to
really push this type of inspirational
development through a large organization?
Is that everything from personal
coaching for their leaders in addition to
retreats?
And what are sort of the levers that you
use to help actually push this through
in a meaningful way
across a big organization?
Okay. Well first of all, no one ever
says you have all the money you want,
but that my brain web chimps,
uh, well, so a couple of things.
Obviously I'm a big believer
in coaching. So I, there,
there is something really powerful and
I became a coach because I had a coach
and it just changed.
He changed my life.
And so I want it to be able to offer
that to other people and hopefully,
I don't know if I changed their lives,
but I, I try really hard to, uh,
to be in service to them.
Uh,
is that personal coaching changes
things because it's just such a unique
development opportunity.
It's so personalized and uh,
and it really allows you to ask the
questions that you want to ask in a very
safe setting, uh, with someone who
isn't invested in your outcome.
They just want you to be successful.
So nobody's trying to gain the system.
So That's why I think coaching is
very effective. Um, but beyond that,
if I could work in an organization,
however I wanted to,
what I think is most effective is
when you introduce concepts to a,
a swath of people.
So maybe it's a all leaders in,
in an office or whatever the case is.
Um,
so everybody gets a sort of the
same song book, if you will,
certainly starts to think about
things a little differently. Uh,
and then you have some sort of breakout
cohort groups underneath of that.
Because I think back to the role
modeling and the conversation,
I think that's what really starts
to get people to think, okay,
how can I really embed
this in my day to day? Uh,
and you get economies of scale that way
because the conversation gets richer and
everybody gets curious and they
start looking at other things.
So I think it's a combination of those
that can really help shift the culture.
Uh, but let me just say that anything
that I wrote about in this book,
the last book, I always tell people this,
it's, it's not hard stuff. Uh, it's,
it's not like you read and
you're like, wow, listening,
I never thought about listening before.
Uh, you know, it, we just don't do it.
Uh, and so part of my work, what I try
to do is really to close that knowing,
doing gap.
So you know it,
but then how do you make it
easier to actually just do it? Uh,
and so I try to make it
very accessible for people.
And so when I come in and work with teams,
that's really what it's about.
You know, I'm not there to tell you
something you've never heard before.
I'm there to get you to do things you
probably know you already should be doing.
Um, but you don't do. Yeah.
And that's really what it is.
Sometimes it's good to have a reminder,
you know,
for folks in this room and folks across
Google. Yeah. You talk about it. These,
these concepts are not difficult,
right? This simple concept.
It's not rocket science,
but a lot of times to some folks
in a company like this, uh,
coding, uh, search
algorithms is very simple.
Listening actually is
not that simple for them.
It's something that they do have
to practice. And something that,
that that seems like
a very simple concept,
but outside of kind of what they're used
to is it takes a little bit of extra
kind of focus and, uh, elbow grease to
kind of make sure that it happens. Right.
Kind of the last question I had because
you mentioned this here and the answer
to Ashley's question was around coaching
and you mentioned that you had a coach
yourself and kind of drove
you in the right direction.
Can you kind of talk about that process
a little bit? Because we all know,
we talk about inspiration, we're
talking about presence. Um,
I think one thing that we all look for
a here is finding coaches that can help
us along our paths as
well to become better, uh,
inspirational leaders to become
better employees and things like that.
Can you talk about that coaching and
coaching kind of atmosphere that you just
mentioned and,
and talk a little bit about your coach
and how that person was inspiring to you.
Sure. Well, I, I, uh, you know, I've
been an entrepreneur since I was 27,
so I didn't have a,
an organization full of people
to role model and mentor me.
And in very early on, I got
introduced to someone who was a coach,
a leadership coach for a small
business owners. And it was,
it was just immensely helpful.
I mean, in so many ways, but,
but probably the most is that it was
somebody I could be very frank with and,
and he had, you know, had had a
business for, you know, 20 or 30 years.
And so there wasn't anything I came up
with had already been through five times,
you know,
so it was really nice just to have a
little bit of normalizing of things that
were happening. Uh, but also somebody that
could really just push my thinking and,
and have just sort of no bs,
uh, allowed and the discussion,
you know, it just sort of
call you on stuff and, and
really make you accountable,
but in a very supportive way.
And that's just a very unusual dynamic
to have somebody who will push you,
support you at the same time has
experienced, they can bring that,
help you understanding
contextually what's going on. Um,
and that doesn't have any sort
of game and your outcomes.
So they're not going to fire you if you
don't do it, what you just talked about.
Right. It, it's really you, it's
your development opportunity.
You do what you want to with it. Uh, and
I find with my clients now as a coach,
uh, you know, my job is to be supportive
and my job is to be incredibly honest.
So, uh, I don't hold back with my clients.
I think they need to hear what my
observations are. That's what I'm,
that's what I'm there for. Uh, and,
and I try to really adjust to their
learning styles so they can hear it in the
best way. Um, you know,
but my investment is in their
success and that's it. And,
and I think the best
coaches look at it that way.
Great. Awesome. Well, Kristy, thank
you so much for coming in today.
We appreciate it. This was very inspiring
for us appropriately. Um, again,
in the book,
the Inspiration Code,
if you guys haven't grabbed a copy on the
way out, I think it's, it's not right.
It comes out on Thursday.
So we have advanced copies.
How great is that? So, um,
if you have it grab a book,
you can read it before the general public
even gets to put their hands on it.
So once again, thank you Christie
for coming and we appreciate it.
Thanks for joining.
So that's happening.